foreign
[Music]
so today I'm going to be talking about
shiny for python
without a server running python
so shiny for R has been around for 10
years now it's kind of hard to believe
and if you want to deploy one of these
applications
you have to have a server oops whoa
sorry this clicker is a little sensitive
have to have a server running r
running shiny
and yesterday Joe announced shiny for
python
and if you want to deploy one of these
apps you have to have a server
running python running shiny
but there's another option where you can
have a server that's running nothing
now before I go in depth explaining what
that means I want to tell a story about
um
about the early days of shiny so this
was back in 2013 China had been had been
around for about a year and we had a
server that was available where people
could deploy their applications and
people were putting all sorts of
interesting stuff there because there's
you know scientists are using R and
shiny and they're doing all sorts of
cool different things one of the
applications that showed up
uh was a quiz
by somebody who was a graduate student
in statistics at the time named Josh
Katz
so um long time users of shinier know
what this is about this is uh this is
this is one of the questions that he had
on the quiz so
what do you call the insect that flies
around in the summer and has a rear
section that glows in the dark
so you could say you could answer this
lightning bug Firefly I use them
interchangeably or other so
people would go to this they'd select
their answer and it would display a map
so in the green areas here this is where
people tend to say Firefly the blur ears
are where people tend to say lightning
bug in the red areas are where people
use those two words interchangeably
all right let's just do one more
for fun
I can get it to go okay how do you
pronounce mayonnaise
um
so with three syllables mayonnaise with
two syllables mayonnaise or I use both
interchangeably
all right until so here's the map in red
is where people tend to say mayonnaise
and in blue is where people say
mayonnaise and the green is where people
use them interchangeably but there
doesn't seem to be a lot on this map
all right so uh so uh you'd answer a lot
of these questions and at the end it
would generate a map for you
sorry
it would generate a map for you showing
how similar your personal dialect is to
Regional dialects in the United States
now this isn't my map but this is this
is actually pretty close to to me
um
the red is where your dialect is more
similar to the regional dialect so in
this case it's most similar to Northern
California and blue is where it's least
similar
now these Maps were all generated
dynamically and um that was a little bit
computationally expensive
so but when you when you're dealing with
like four or five people that's not you
know four or five simultaneous users
that's not a big deal but um this got
out into some I believe it got into some
Linguistics blog and then it got picked
up by media uh this is Business Insider
there was an article that ended up here
and my understanding actually was that
this was the most popular article on
their website that year
so it got picked up here and some other
outlets and it ended up driving a lot of
traffic
to our server
so at some point we had uh thousands of
simultaneous users and our server went
down and we had to spin up new servers
in AWS to handle all that computational
load
uh and this is this was back before we
had these automated scaling and hosting
systems that we have now
so there's a very manual process ended
up being very expensive we spent
thousands of dollars running all these
servers but we survived
um but you know this this raises an
interesting question which is wouldn't
it be nice if we didn't have to do all
that computation on the server
so what are some ways of not doing the
computation on the server one thing you
can do is
maybe you can pre-compute the results so
sometimes
you can do this
and sometimes you can't
oh sorry
clicker problems here
okay sometimes you can't so some of
those Maps could have been pre-generated
and actually Josh changed his app to do
that and but that final one with your
personalized map could not be
all right what about doing computation
on the client
well you have a couple options here so
one is to do the computation in the web
browser
but if you know something about web
browsers you know that uh the only
language they understand is Javascript
so that's that's and so therefore you
must write your application application
in JavaScript and uh that can be a
problem if you're doing data science
because a lot of the tools that you're
used to
um
might not exist in JavaScript
so how about another option
send the code and data to the client and
let the user run the code on their
computer so in order to do this though
you need to you need to duplicate your
Computing environment on their computer
and doing this duplicating your
Computing environment is difficult and
it's it's a lot of work and you can't
reasonably expect Somebody To You Know
take that survey that fun survey and
have to install you know R and or python
in a whole bunch of packages just to do
that
well this is actually
the story of how things were back then
but things have changed
so
this part here about web browsers can
only run JavaScript
that's actually no longer true
and the Corollary
is also not true anymore
so what other language do web browsers
support now well there's something
called webassembly or sometimes
abbreviated wasm
this is a binary format for programs
that can run in web browsers
it's not a language that you'd write by
hand normally usually you'd write code
in C or C plus plus or some other
languages and compile it to webassembly
and then you can run it in the browser
at near native speeds
so turns out python is written in C
and there's actually a port of python
called piadide
which compiles to webassembly and can
run in the web browser
and of course I have to mention web R
which is a project that George Stagg
started is working on which is our
compile the web assembly but this is
still in the early stages so I'm not
going to talk more about it in this
presentation
all right so let's go back to doing
computation on the client
so
this this in option two here this
problem here duplicating a Computing
environment is difficult well actually
if you compile your Computing
environment to webassemble you can send
it
to the the web browser and this actually
becomes very easy to duplicate the
Computing environment so we'll cross
that out and then we have this new
combination of options one and two so
we'll send the code and data and the
Computing environment in webassembly to
the client and then run all of that in
the web browser
all right so we have done this with
shiny so we've put together shiny
and Python and webassembly and we put it
together to something that we are
calling shiny live
all right so I'm not going to tell you
more a whole lot more about it right now
I'm just going to show you what you can
do with it so how many people here have
gone to the documentation website for
shiny for python
okay so if you did that that's great
um
you might have seen something like this
so this is this web page here and then
there's a running application there
and uh
well I'll just show you that it's
actually running well this is this is
just a video but
so
this is a histogram you move a slider
and you know it it regenerates some data
and redraws the histogram
okay so what you might not have known is
that you are already using shiny live
these applications on the website are
not hosted on a server that's running
python these these examples all are all
running inside of the web browser
so you can go and you can make changes
to this application
we'll do it up here let's just
change this one so it generates a
uniform distribution
so I'll take out some of the UI stuff
make some UI modifications don't worry
about the details about this you just
know that you just have to know that I'm
changing some code
and um
after we make those changes then you can
hit the play button and you can see that
it now it's generating uniform
distribution so again all of that the
editor
and this application viewer panel and
shiny itself all of that is running
inside the web browser there's no server
running python
all right now so what are some other fun
things you can do with this
all right
um if you start on the main web page
and then there's an examples button you
can click to see to browse some examples
there's this you don't have to be able
to really read it but on the sidebar
there's some interesting examples there
one of them is a simulation of the moon
orbiting the Earth
all right I'm just gonna
so what we have here is the code editor
and then the running application over
there and again this is all running
inside the web browser there's no
there's no server in the back running
python
so you can make changes to the initial
speed of the Earth and then if you do
that you can see how the moon will
follow it as it orbits but let's say you
know I want to make some changes to this
this app is a little complicated I want
to simplify a little bit so um
let's go ahead and do that
really fast
so you can yeah you can make these
changes right in the browser and rerun
the application
and try all sorts of new things out
all right so here we are
we've simplified the application a
little bit I know it looks pretty
similar but it is actually simpler and
this is you know maybe we've learned a
lot about using shiny by doing this now
you might want to share this with people
right normally to do that you would have
to
um
deploy it to some server that's that's
running shiny
but there's another option here with
shiny live and I'm going to zoom in a
little bit I know this still may be hard
to see but I'll show it even closer
later so if there's a share button and
then when you click on that it'll
provide these two uh sharing links
and one of the the top one says editor
URL and you can copy that URL
send it to somebody and when they paste
it in their web browser
um they'll open it up
and they'll see the application running
in their browser as well and they have
that editor panel and the running
application
so this is good if the person you're
sending it to is interested in the code
and looking at it or modifying it
but maybe the person is not interested
in that maybe they just want to see the
application itself so there's another
link application URL
you can copy that
and send it to them
and then if they if they put that in
their browser
it'll open it up and it'll be running
that application in the full window
all right so you might be wondering like
hey
um
how much does this cost how do I sign up
for this
um and the answer to those questions is
it doesn't cost anything and you don't
have to sign up for anything to use this
so we'll take a look at this URL this
might help explain things a little bit
so this is what the URL looks like so
it's a shinylive.io pi slash editor and
then code equals and then there's this
big string so that's actually that
string is actually that whole
application code encoded into the URL
and when you make a request when you
send that to somebody and they go visit
that
the web browser
makes a request just for this first part
the part in blue
so it requests shiny live hey send me
all this shiny live stuff the uh you
know webassembly and JavaScript stuff
and python stuff of course
it does not send this part to the server
that part is just in their browser and
so the browser then takes shiny live
decodes the application and then runs it
all inside the browser so that means
that the server is just serving these
files without having to think about it
just sends out tons of files and that's
really easy for for web servers to do
now
you might be thinking well sharing shiny
apps with a URL that's that might be fun
but
maybe the app and data is too big to
make a reasonably sized URL I mean
browsers can actually handle from
testing I found a really large URLs
these days like even in the megabytes
but that's that you don't typically want
to do send a huge URL like that
um maybe it feels weird just it feels
weird to encode an app in a giant URL
um that just seems strange
or maybe
if I can get this clicker to work maybe
I don't want to depend on the server at
shinyapps.io
which I don't have any control over well
I have control over it but
you don't
so another option is to deploy your
shiny live application
so in order to do this there's uh
there's two steps the first is to save
your shiny live assets and application
files to a directory
and then upload that directory to a web
hosting service like GitHub Pages or
netlify Amazon S3 or cloudflare Pages if
you're old school you can use an Apache
web server or you can deploy it to
rstudio connect which is useful because
it provides uh authentication and access
control if you don't want the whole
world to be able to see the application
and let me show you how this works so
it's pretty simple
all right
okay let's say I have my application
files in a directory called my app
now there's a then there's a a command
line tool that comes with shiny for
python called shiny and you say shiny
static my app site so site is the
directory that we're writing it to
and it copies it downloads and copies
the shiny life assets and puts them in
there and then also copies the
application files and puts them in there
and so now we have a directory we'll
take a look here directory called site
and then and then we can test hey can I
actually serve this site directory and
uh and have people run my application
so we'll just run a the simple web
server python web server and look at
visit localhost
and then it will load the application
right here
all right now at this point this is when
you can take that those that set of
files and just upload it to your static
web hosting service whatever that may be
okay let's take a look at the deployment
model here so for traditional shiny app
deployment you have a server that's
running r or running Python and
computers connect to it and they may
when they connect to it they maintain
this open connection they you know the
user interacts with it a little bit it
sends data to the server the server does
some computation and it sends some
information back
for shiny Live app deployment you have a
server that doesn't run our python
when the user connects to it
it sends a
it sends Python and the app code
and shiny of course to those computers
and all of that stuff runs inside of
those client computers and it's very
easy for a server to just send those
files that's that's not a
computationally intensive thing to do so
it can serve you can serve a lot of
users this way
okay let's talk about the benefits of
shiny live to summarize so the entire
application runs on the client instead
of the server so there's no
computational load on the server
it's really easy to share these
applications
it's easy to deploy them to a static web
hosting service and it's easy to scale
them because that's what these static
web hosting services do that's that's um
that's their bread and butter
it's very cheap
and it works on devices without python
installed so like Chromebooks or iPads
or phones and this is not just for
viewing the application but you can even
edit the applications and and play with
it on there
so it's not
uh it's not all sunshine and rainbows
there's also some a few drawbacks and
limitations
so one is that not all packages are
available in piadite so piad contains a
lot of packages in the python scientific
stack including pandas and matplotlib
but not all packages for python you can
install packages from Pi Pi if they're
written in pure Python and don't have
any compiled code so but hopefully you
know hopefully this situation will
improve in the future but that's what it
is right now
the code and data for the application is
sent to the web web browser so there's
no secrets somebody can in principle
look at all the code and data for your
application
if they can see your app
it's not good for large amounts of data
like if you've got 100 megabytes of data
that your application is operating on
you probably don't want to send that to
somebody's web browser that's that's a
lot it's not unheard of but that is a
lot
so the download side so download size
for a basic application the browser will
download about 13 megabytes of stuff
and um unless you're loading packages
from there like uh like pandas it's just
going to go up from there
but fortunately browser caching will
speed up subsequent visits so uh the
first time somebody views it it might be
slow and especially in this conference
Wi-Fi the first time you visit one of
these may be a little bit slow but then
in later visits it should be really
really fast
okay
and finally the browser security sandbox
restricts network connectivity
but the good news is if shiny live
doesn't work for your application you
always have the option to do a
traditional shiny app deployment you can
learn this one framework shiny and when
it's appropriate deploy it with shiny
live and if that doesn't work for you
can deploy it as with a traditional
deployment
just by learning one framework
okay so
um this is where you can learn more
about it shiny.rstudio.com Pi there's a
link at the top for shinylife
so also it's it's still experimental
please keep that in mind we're still
learning a lot about it and um
you know so we can't wait to see what
you're going to do with it because we
want to learn what kinds of
possibilities people are what what what
the possibilities are and hopefully
you'll be able to teach us that
and of course I know everyone is
thinking about this
yes we're hoping to do this with shiny
for R but uh there's a lot of work that
needs to be done before we can get
started on this
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]